[Music]
welcome to an episode the episode of
tiger belly I am your captain and I'm
your leader
Bobbie Lee and I have my beautiful
girlfriend koala
kalila [ __ ] and we've got Gilbert and
let me says before I introduce our guest
I just want to say that I this is a
dream been a dream of mine I whenever I
see Margaret I I just get gaga
do you feel that from me Margaret yeah
it's well as you should because I'm a
little bit older than you know so we
thank you this is my girlfriend kalila
she's also Filipino beautiful thank you
nice to meet you very lovely lady thank
you thank you and I have to say this is
that um the reason why I get Gaga is
because of the fact that I am I don't
know if I'd be doing stand-up without
you because I think in the mid 90s maybe
I saw you on your HBO special you were
young I've never really had heard of you
before and I was watching you and I go
it was the first time you saw somebody
that Asian and also specifically Korean
that had a voice that you could relate
to you know because I had seen Tamiya
Otsuki on something and she doesn't
thick accent I love to my oh she's great
she's great she's she's insane and funny
yeah I didn't really relate to her and
Johnny youn was a little too way too old
for me he was older but here's a woman
that's a girl who's Korean who is hip
and he's you know attitude and very
American and I was just like oh she's
the female version of me and a year
later I started doing stand-up I love
that yeah and you and I are very similar
in many we've struggled with things yeah
that's a different thing
yeah yuck yeah yeah yeah yeah yuck over
the years we've needed it yeah
and now Yakima WA Nimal listen ah any
subtitles to edit not go to much
[Music]